what's up everybody Christy's got a
brand new hour of stand-up material I'm
coming to Vancouver February 22nd Fresno
California February 24th February 25th
San Jose February 26 Sacramento and then
guess what baby Boston we've added a
fourth show at the wilba a fourth show
at the Wilbur in Boston West Palm Beach
uh March 28th 29th Miami March 31st
Austin Texas April 12th
christycomedy.com for all the tiki wikis
and then guess what on sale tomorrow all
these new cities Fort Myers Florida
Orlando Florida Jacksonville Florida
Tampa Florida San Antonio Texas second
show in Buffalo New York Ithaca New York
Albany New York and Newport Rhode Island
christycomedy.com those ones are on sale
tomorrow all the other ones on sale
right now Boston Vancouver Austin
everybody's coming Pat summer for
Lebanese president guys the Impractical
Jokers live tour is back a national tour
right now first time in three years
tickets are on sale right now now and
impracticaljokerslive.com tonight we are
in Pittsburgh Pennsylvania at the PPG
Paints Arena uh tomorrow we have the
freedom mortgage Pavilion in Camden New
Jersey uh bring some pepper spray uh on
on the 4th February 4th on Saturday
we're at the Wang theater in Boston for
two and then all the dates are up there
in North Charleston Charlotte Waterloo
uh and uh Washington after that big one
here is Niagara Falls and Newark New
Jersey and Prudential and uh UBS arena
in Long Island and then keep keep
checking out that they I don't know what
I'm saying anymore but it's Green Bay
it's Milwaukee it's Rosemont in Seattle
Portland and uh Denver and all [__] like
that Columbus Cleveland Detroit
Minneapolis Des Moines you get it Kansas
City if you live in a town in here we're
coming to you Nashville Indianapolis St
Louis we love to see you on the road the
show started last weekend we're having a
blast doing them practicaljokerslive.com
bye
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey babe
people are talking
about hey babe I hear them whisper you
won't believe
just a little too loud and we stand just
a little too close we stand just a
little too long
maybe they're seeing
something we don't darling let's give
them something or hey babe about hey
babe how are you babe first of all yeah
you look good thanks you too you look
because what I like about you oh here's
what I like about you okay it's because
you're a guy who even if I didn't I'm a
guy I am a guy
here's the thing about you okay is even
if I didn't know you even if I wasn't
friends with you even if I have never
seen you on TV you're one of the guys
you walk outside with a beanie cap and
glasses like that I don't hate you I say
even though that look is normally
designated for people that are like very
annoying you look like one of those guys
who I'm like but not him oh thanks he's
the guy you're actually should be the
face of this movement because uh have a
likability that oozes through you even
when you want to dress like a barista in
Portland thank you so much
and that from the neck up I guess I am
you would make you would make uh a Nazi
uniform look good oh thank you so much
as you would make you would make a Nazi
uniform look good I think if I put an
answer from people would be upset by
that because I think I'd just look a
little too much like the books I mean
when I say look good I mean look as
intended yeah you mean you mean it would
look like we'd be going back a time and
yeah yeah like you should be you should
be casting like Shameless list too that
Schindler's List too right now that if
that is the calling the calling uh yeah
open casting for that yeah you show up
for that I go and get online you show up
well I wouldn't even have you read no
I'd be like I look at you and be like
yeah you're like Hitler's right hand
yeah well you know what's funny is it's
funny you mentioned that yeah I I did a
show I was doing shows in Phoenix uh
this weekend shout out Phoenix love
Phoenix Scottsdale shout out Scottsdale
and um Phoenix that's capital of the
United States it is yeah I was doing my
Thursday night show whatever
walking out to the car you know fans
from the show came up came up to me oh
you know nice things whatever and then
she goes she's there with her husband
she goes me and my husband say it all
the time we cannot believe you've never
been cast in any war movies
it's like what yeah because I could also
picture with that World War One helmet
oh yeah you know that one that looks
like um it just looks like a like a bowl
on your head a little bit like is that
what is that world war one yeah you ever
seen the German World War One helmets
when they just have that point the point
like a Christmas ornament yeah yeah you
know helmets have come a long way
helmets have come along more helmets
also though we regressed because that's
a beautiful what is that that's not a
Hitler that's a German word that's a j
okay so this is a World War One helmet
where yes they were the nation of
Germany but they weren't Nazis okay so
but they still are enemy back then oh
they were still an enemy well they were
they World War one it was Germany really
Germany versus Britain and we came and
helped Britain so yes technically
Germany's our enemy but okay not as big
of our enemy in World War II but look at
the old world craftsmanship on that
helmet you Scott listen here's the thing
yeah okay if you things are I know the
uh World improves and whatever and
Technology you can't really beat the
craftsmanship yeah and the sturdiness of
old things yeah they just were built
from homes to cars to ever to Nazi
helmets let me if if you had a choice
yeah it's the same price we all have a
choice that is true we all well
we're here with free will we are here I
don't know if you read the Bible
you're right it is well the Book of Job
Book of Job good chapters five through
eight
two do you think do you know that
there's people out there people probably
listen to our podcast
hey please continue do you think
um there are people there that they
literally every word can recite every
word from the Bible from front to back
every word you say Job chapter five they
know it exactly do you do you think your
mind has that capacity to hold all that
info the Bible's a thick book isn't it
it's thick as [__] yeah right yo she
looking
your Bible is thick with two C's bro the
Bible though is tricky even because they
also split the pages into two columns so
don't they do they but I guess that's
just the same amount of words we don't
have homeless pimp here today we have uh
Pat we call him Patty Clips Paddy Clips
Pat Yamaha how do you say your last name
Samaha Pat Samaha oh wow yeah uh so how
do you spell it
s-a-m-a-h-a Oh I thought that's what I
would have guessed it's like Yamaha with
that right social social security number
yeah Pat is a great um videographer he
works for Karen feehan's podcast he
works for he does a lot of the clips
that you may see that I put out on my uh
social media Pat will put out uh he's
known as Lebanese lightning the Lebanese
lightning oh the Levee lights gets
things quick yeah and uh and yeah and
and Pat say uh he's a sexy he's a sexy
Lebanese mofo sure and he's and he's and
he's been kind enough here to fill in
for pimping smile he just wants to be
paid in hummus oh okay well he has
plenty of that you need hummus we got
you baby oh that's good stuff I don't
know he's had a job couldn't make it
today because he's actually
um filming uh a really cool thing that
you guys will see soon hopefully for
Chaz commentary oh right on I know yes
yes yes so so yeah so Patty actually
saved us so thanks to Pat Pat saved the
day as Lebanon mostly does save the day
yeah yeah a lot of times and it's a nice
it's it's nice to have some diversity in
here also it is it's nice well yeah well
you know you live in a diverse home I do
live in a day and I'm half diverse right
I always forget you're Cuban yeah and
Puerto Rican correct and Italian a
little Spanish Spanish for Spain from
you know somebody somebody actually
brought something up that was
interesting the other day and I I didn't
have an answer they said you know people
from Spain right you just call them
Spanish and they're you'll say oh from
Spanish you would incorrectly say
they're Latino no they're not they're
European but why is everybody else in
Europe white but the Spanish are Spanish
and I said wow he said you wouldn't call
an Italian in Italian you would but you
they're white right right you're white
European why but you designate Spain and
I said I never thought about that yeah
because a lot of Spaniards are not
necessarily they are they they are the
Caucasian look like like they they look
white a lot of Spaniards and everybody
they're Spanish yeah like we say oh you
know oh that guy's Spanish that guy's
Spanish it's all because Spain came at
some point in the last 500 years and
colonized birth control yeah
came and colonized them and then so in a
way it's like it's almost like don't
call that person Spanish try to say you
know they're Honduran they're Mexican
they're Puerto Rican because they were
conquer it's like if you still called us
British it's like no no no right beat
them exactly they left exactly right and
you know when I was growing up I used to
tell people for the longest time because
I didn't realize it
for the longest time
I used to say I'm half Italian half
Spanish which is incorrect well it's not
incorrect it's just it's it's it's it's
it's you should be more precise I'm
Spanish and Hispanic right and Cuban now
what's the difference between Spanish
and Hispanic does anybody know or that
that's too hard of a question uh Spanish
ends in ish and then you take that off
and you put the I and the H in the front
that's the difference Spanish and they
take the
Hispanic Pat yes Pat has pulled up
hispanic refers to people who speak
Spanish or are descended from
Spanish-speaking populations while
Latino refers to people who are from or
descended from people from Latin America
so well this is interesting because
what's a Puerto Rican is not from either
your Caribbean so I think are you
afro-caribbean I I might be I don't I
didn't right and then Cuban
is kind of
also not we should name this episode
what is a Puerto Rico who am I are You
My Mother
um people that know the whole Bible uh
memorized that that's for me for me yeah
a bit much yeah a bit much so I would
think that if we had a lights up if we
if we had live viewership of a map of
the United States watching right now the
South just Lights Went dim the southern
states just said you need to know every
word of the Bible if I think it's the
southern states I'll say this in the
South if I see someone in the South yeah
who knows every word of the Bible yeah I
agree it's like okay whatever but it's
almost expected it's more freaky to me
if you're from the North like if you're
from the north and you're like one of
these Brooklyn guys and you're like yo I
can quote yo bro yo bro let me tell you
something right now Revelations yeah 69
420 bro yeah I would say oh you've went
to prison yeah yeah like I would assume
you went to prison right where the South
I would assume you not necessarily have
to go yeah right yeah yeah I think
that's what it is yeah a lot of people
find God up in that and up in that fine
God up in that [__] in the pen yeah
um I don't yeah well I was gonna say
that I've been lately first of all I've
two updates for you
oh wow it's one I got what are you a
Macbook yes
I like it thank you
one one yes I for weeks
every time I peed it would burn and then
I would always feel like I have leftover
urine in the tip of my urethra and it
would feel like a little Pebble in the
front of my penis
and I would say I know it's not an STD I
know it's not an STD because I'm not out
there [__] no I know it I know it I
know it's not an STD so I felt
comforting with that yeah but then that
Comfort turned to fear because I said at
least if I was out there [__] I would
know what I have to do right and then
you just go get your pills and you were
being a bad boy but I wasn't so then it
turned to fear and it's not an STD what
is it right so I was worried about
kidney stones I was worried about
bladder cancer I was worried about all
these things at the internet and the
people who are doctors and family this
is in the Bible too yeah they'll just
give you advice yeah well they used to
throw uh kidney stones at uh prostitutes
yes yeah which they deserved it no what
do they call stones kidney stones
gallstones which ones coming out of you
kidding yourself kidney stones okay
which I've heard for a male is the least
excruciating pain I heard it's like
giving birth it's like giving birth yes
but you ready for this you ready for
what it was probably not I went on a
road trip
uh I I went on you know to do shows I
forgot I was using this pre-workout
every day I would just take it like with
coffee it was like a a mushroom magic
blend pre-workout that one of my friends
from Colombia sent me a little shake and
I was feeling good in the gym give me
all this energy I stopped taking it for
three days because I forgot it P went
went away that burning immediately has
not come back since so there's a lot of
times we take these powdered drinks and
these supplements or whatever but your
body's like oh hell no hell no and don't
even oh no you didn't yes so that's the
first update the second update the best
sleep I've ever had in my life came last
night I only slept for six hours but I
slept from the minute I put my head on
the pillow and fell asleep to woke up
this morning tell me I feel like I have
so much energy I do I genuinely don't
know what to do with it and it's
actually scary because I actually feel
your energy yeah and I'm not kidding
since I got here that's why I have to
bring it up to you because I know that I
I'm I'm being myself but it's a
heightened version of myself and that I
can't control and it's simply because I
got six hours of uninterrupted sleep out
of bed like you can't imagine oh wait
okay so I thought you were gonna say you
got six hours the best of your life
because you took something like you just
came off the taking the powder and then
you like another update I got the best
seat of my life last night and I thought
you're gonna say because I took this
supplement oh right you just got the
best living life by chance no I forgot
this part is I got I was on Thursday
when I went to Phoenix I got sick I was
not like a bad cold and when I was
Landing in the plane I had six shows in
Phoenix five at the House of Comedy and
then a corporate gig for DraftKings
shout out DraftKings shout out to the
king shout out to the DraftKings and
queens yeah so and princes and everybody
princesses I love them all to draft
peasants even
the giraffe surfs yeah so what happened
was yeah is is is my friend who's a
doctor I gotta see how that gig went
back ahead said he said to me because
I'm sorry when I was Landing in the
plane you know like when your ears it
didn't it not only did it on not unclog
you know that pain that you realize you
stayed with that stayed with it that
pain is excruciating I was in I was I
was at the hotel oh no laying in the bed
with my pillow it wouldn't go away
because that you had someone had an
infection because I had a sinus
infection already a previous sinus
infection already and I had um I had um
all this residual you take a
decongestant I tried to do all that
wasn't working so I called my friend
who's a doctor and I just said buddy I'm
sorry like what can you do he said I'm
gonna send you prednisone a steroid and
Amoxicillin an antibiotic he said just
because I don't I haven't tested I don't
know if it's a virus
I'm sending you a z-pack right and a
steroid pack he sent you a z send me a z
I thought you weren't supposed to you're
not take those will nil well that's the
thing you're not but he said you are
telling me I would never want to do this
for you but you're telling me you got
six shows right you gotta get get
through a big weekend yeah you're this
this at the very least will make you
feel like a million bucks sure at the
very least gonna make you feel great and
so that's what I took and and because
what I think happened is I took the
prednisone I think number one that gives
you so much energy but I think the maybe
the amoxicillin and all that whatever
sinus infection I have I think that it
made my tonsils get a little bit smaller
because they've just been sitting here
being infected for weeks and weeks and
weeks on end but you just get used to it
that it shrunk my tonsils enough that
air got through and I had like I think I
have sleep apnea and I bring it up
because I know that you and you have had
it I think I have it I think I need the
apnea mask yeah so I'm asking you two
questions one can I borrow your apnea
yes and two
um not really a question but a statement
but I think the amoxicillin uh also I
think I did have chlamydia and I think
the amoxicillin did not get it because
the amoxicillin just does that and I
must have had chlamydia from three years
ago yeah
you had
I was trying to combine the words
residual and chlamydia
um
um I had uh uh clementious it didn't
work I thought I was gonna connect
what I was thinking okay yeah uh you can
borrow my mask it's just I need it when
I'm sleeping so come over I'll sleep you
watch me then you sleep and I'll watch
it yeah yeah if you if you have that you
should get uh something right away I
know we've said this before but this was
on an earlier episode so I you know
what's up everybody if you know one
thing about me you know the only thing I
love more than my own family is ship
station
I love ship station make ship happen if
you're running a business and you don't
have ship station you can expect your
business to go put it's out of here it's
not getting bailed out by the
governments neither ship station makes
things so easy okay it literally all
your customized orders everything you
have to send out to customer ship
station makes it happen it's free fast
shipping they manage every order from
one simple dashboard automate routine
shipping task print shipping labels
everything over 130 000 companies have
grown their e-commerce businesses with
ship station and 98 of those companies
have stuck with ship station for over a
year and they are customers for life
keep growing your business all year long
with ship station go use the promo code
hey babe today at shipstation.com to
sign up for your free 60-day trial
that's shipstation.com promo code hey
babe make ship happen I said this once
uh I think it was a very early episode
of hey babe there was a time where Sal
and I used to go on the road together
right and Sal and Sal we got like you
know we had we had a hotel room where it
was like kind of a two-bedroom hotel
room right he had his room I I admined
so it was like a section right and we
had to be let's say at the airport at
let's say 11 A.M right so we talked the
night before you got to get up by 9 30.
whatever it is
I get up I'm up early whatever and I
hear Sal's alarm going off I hear it
going off right for like whatever five
minutes I'm like he'll get it I take a
shower full shower brush my teeth I'm in
there 20 minutes his alarm's still going
off and I was like oh my God so I go in
there and I'm like wow
he has his cell phone on his face like
this with the alarm going off full blast
not waking up at all this is how nervous
I got I called a member of his family
yes and said I think Sal is passed
this is how he is and then I shook you
and because of that damn sleep apne Mass
you get the deepest best sleep yeah yeah
yes yes I told you that that I didn't
know when I when I went to take it they
put me in overnight and they hooked me
up to it yeah and the guy said that that
was the first time I slept that deeply
in 15 years wow and did you you truly
felt like a different person for real oh
it was very strange when I woke up from
that test the next morning with a mask
for the first time ever like I drove
when I drove home I my body my mind felt
different than I had I didn't know the
feeling I was feeling do you feel now
because
you sleep with it all the time you're
just used to that feeling and you forgot
about what you used to feel like or do
you think it's kind of worn off and
balanced out now no no I'll never forget
what I used to feel like because it was
so bad because I I couldn't keep my eyes
open during the day you could never have
the schedule in life you have now
without sleep apnea mask no no way no
way if I sometimes if I like for some
reason I find myself where I don't have
it it's it's the terrible if you forgot
your sleep apnea mask on a five-day road
trip would you have to have somebody
FedEx it out to you it's happened two or
three times already you have to yeah I
mean overnight FedEx I can't I don't
want to go one I could do it but it will
not get good sleep and the next day I
will be like so exhausted I was like be
falling asleep like you could fall
asleep at the wheel is dangerous right
and now you're used to it yeah now I I
don't even think twice it I don't even
feel it but technology is like you know
you know technology keeps like you know
technology keeps being updated right 100
yeah so yeah now I'm seeing stuff where
like you could wear something or like
get something put on your I don't know
that that's they're changing the game
apparently right in the CPAP world right
they're changing the Gap world big time
I would think that there's have to have
been couples who are married who like
you know are used to you know midnight
middle of the night sex that a man has
had sex with his wife with the sleep
apnea mask fully on the whole time if
you just want to get it over right away
or something I mean I know I I've never
even thought of that but it probably is
only fantastic I mean that is that's it
that's actually probably very unique a
niche market a niche market yeah you're
doing your only fans Sal's only fence
but it's sleep apnea South yes like a
sexy sleepout there's no obstruction
here and it's all by force there right
and everything that's going on up here
is taking care of itself and everything
that's going to um down there yeah in
and of itself is taking care of itself
yeah but I can't have this without being
inconvenienced right taking that off and
how nice is it to have an only fans with
the sleep apnea mask on you don't have
to think about hair and makeup you don't
have to and you don't have to worry
about it it's not really a lot you have
to say what do you say people are there
for the mask that's it just let the mask
do its job here's another thing I want
to speak to you about I watched while I
was in my hotel room uh did you watch
blackbird
Blackbird what's black bird okay no I
thought you could say Blackbird is that
an is it I think we talked about a movie
on Netflix I think we talked about it
it's a show on I think Apple TV six
episodes so far it's a six episode four
seasons blown off
balls off it's off balls way
it's it's yeah it's Bullets Over balls
uh it's it's a it's a it's it's a bit
it's with the guy I got it
Walter Hauser you know he's also in um
he's in everything in the in the Cruella
Deville uh the 100 new 101 Dalmatians
he's great in that movie I'm not
surprised he plays Richard Jewel in
another movie oh that's right that's him
yeah yeah I love that guy this guy is so
funny and awesome this guy is I mean he
came for me out of nowhere he is an
unbelievable actor anyway
Paul Walter if you're listening and we
know that you are and we know you please
open invite shout out Hauser uh shout
out Doogie Hauser and Shout Out Paul
Walter Hauser yes yeah and Shout Out
Casper Hauser who's Casper I don't know
I just know the name um uh so this is so
he's so I'm watching this right and it's
fantastic premise can you give me the
premise I can give you the premise
without giving anything away this is
hard no I can give you the premise get
me get me locked in without giving me
too much I got you tell you how great it
is without telling you how great it is
okay yeah first of all I don't like to
tell people about series like this I
just like I'm going cold but this is
this is what I could do it because you
don't have to figure anything out
basically you ever see the kingsman oh
yeah I love the Kingston That's my boy
right there from the King's Room right
Taryn egerton or whatever his name you
want to talk about a hottie with a body
he's the definition of it yeah yeah he's
got a hottie and he's got his body
anyway he so he plays this guy this
young uh this young kid who gets busted
for uh for moving drugs for dealing
drugs but like that it happens not like
a small time drug deal like kilo drug
dealer type thing his father and this is
Ray Liotta by the way God bless and Ray
Liotta if you if you are listening we
know that you are oh yeah really yeah
because he's still watching from above
he's sitting with Kane Tanaka right now
sit down listen together so see by the
way check it out about so anyway it's
it's almost like I'll know I'll never I
would like to just have his nipple yeah
like even his nipple looks like a nice
tight small nipple it doesn't offend
anybody it's there you have them hear
that thing about how monkey Mark has
three nipples or no nipples or something
like that really yeah remember it was
like a whole thing back in the day when
he did like the campaign for like Calvin
Klein or something and people were like
oh he has three nipples they had to
airbrush one of his nipples out Mark
Wahlberg
see
where's the third nipple
ah okay oh it's like a birthmark no but
I think it's more like a nipple
you know that could I mean it's possible
there's a difference between a birthmark
see look it's all over there's like so
many pictures of his third nip
so okay so what about blackbird so
anyway so so so so there you go
confirmed he has a third nip um so he
plays this guy and it really orders his
dad next cop and he gets sentenced and
he thinks he's gonna get out he's told
that he could plea and get out of her
and he ends up getting like 10 years and
he can't believe it he's a young kid and
he's in there for a while a little you
know and they say there's this serial
killer okay that is about to like they
don't have enough evidence on him and
he's been in jail while but he might be
let go now okay and the guy is a serial
killer they think he's a serial kill
they don't have the proof and they but
and this guy from the kingsman is a
really smooth talking guy like he's like
a personable smooth talking guy they
know his profile okay and they're like
if we transfer you to the prison where
the where this serial killer is which is
like the worst of the worst of the worst
persons all psychotic people so it's
very dangerous and you can get him you
can befriend him and get him to admit
admit that he killed these young girls
these young girls so it kills all
children it's terrible actually it's
pretty gross it kills girls and uh then
we will literally exonerate you and let
you free out of your sentence wow yeah
it's really good too but you don't
understand dude the guy Paul Walter
Hauser is it's like no acting you've
ever seen it's that good so it's this is
a must watch
um he is so I'm watching and I tell my
lady I said I guarantee you I said I
guarantee you I had no idea I go I
guarantee you he's gonna be not at least
nominated for all the awards I guarantee
it
I didn't even know this two days later I
didn't know he's not he won the Golden
Glow for best actor for this two days
later yeah yeah just bang yeah boom he
won it so that's how I I mean I guess I
guess I have a goal I guess I have a
Golden Globe kind of sensibility yeah
you want you um you are you are very
good I'll tell you what I don't think
I'm trying to think if there's ever been
a time where you've steered me wrong but
so far no I as far as watching [__]
you told me about the patient with Steve
did you watch it yeah we never spoke
about that what are you talking about I
don't think we spoke about it after you
watched it
right wrong but I spoke we you put me on
to it what do you think intense as [__]
right you put me on to succession which
changed my whole life
yeah um there's another one
there's another one you put me on too
with severance
Severance you've put me onto but I
haven't watched it yet oh that one's
like yeah I mean come on I put you on to
Yellowstone but now I pull that back I
watch I fell off Yellowstone has fallen
off I watched three and a half seasons
and then I didn't finish the fourth and
I didn't watch the film the last season
is it's become like like a love story
that's uh that's not what I'm watching
Yellowstone for I've heard the other
ones 1883 and 1928 yeah the prequels are
good 1920 is another one now another one
they're getting a little out of control
yeah because it's hard because I might
have even said it might be 1928 and 1880
it might be uh
1928 and 1883 or 1828 1933 I don't know
yeah what are they gonna do now Duo it's
too many years he's gonna do it every
year now yeah it's it's ridiculous but
so what'd you think of the patients I
love the patient how good was that uh
the the killer I mean more great acting
yeah he you had a serial killer who
doesn't typically he doesn't look like
he would be a serial killer because
here's the thing you got to know about
serial killers they come in all shapes
and sizes that's correct and he was also
I'd be surprised if he wasn't nominated
as well they probably nominated a whole
bunch of Serial kills this time yeah
well that's all this that's all
entertainment has become has been do a
show about a serial killer or profile a
serial killer yeah it's too much I I it
is but but I it's gripping though don't
kill cats whatever the hell is called oh
on Netflix don't be afraid to kill don't
be yeah don't [__] with the castle yeah
did you like that
well here's the thing I watched that and
I was like this is
really intense and like it felt like a
very big mystery thrill because they
were saying that the forums were trying
to hunt help the police catch the killer
before the police did right on the board
on the internet forums but then I
watched uh the story of this guy from a
different Viewpoint like a different
like a doc or like a news report or
whatever it was and it was so less
dramatic and it made me realize that you
know they could frame the documentary in
a way like they did an amazing job
because they made it like holy [__] this
is intense and then like the other story
was like uh you know this guy did this
and we found them a couple days later
and I was like oh wow that wasn't the
journey that they took me this guy this
guy you talk about a bit much this guy's
a psycho this guy's extra yo he's x what
did he do again he just he just like I
think he just like like like
he he he took home lovers and then he
would just chop them up and throw them
in the garbage
well at least once what isn't once
enough he would take home lovers chop
him up throw him up and they got throw
them out in the garbage and then oh I
think because at first he was like oh
then he started leaving hints online I
think it's like or he murdered cats I
think was he killed what he killed cats
on a video and he hit his he hit himself
I think or something like that and then
he went on to murder people and but
people didn't like him already because
he [__] with the cats so the people
that were hot on his tail were on his
tail no pun intended because of the cats
I might have that wrong right I
discovered people but they cared less
about that people would
well it's a very common thing for us as
humans is we typically don't care if a
human dies but we get very upset if a
pet dies or if animal dies yeah what do
you think it is because we feel like
they're more helpless and they're more
innocent yes I do what if you what if
your pets aren't in so what if you what
if you got a racist homophobic pet and
you just don't know because they can't
talk to you
but yeah but that when that racist
homeboy pet was born it wasn't like that
and the same same thing with the person
but I just think it's a fact that they
can't take care of themselves
DraftKings baby I love it I am Chrissy
the draft Queen telling you to go to
DraftKings if literally it is the
official sports betting partner of Super
Bowl 57 bang new customers can bet five
dollars and get 203 bets instantly okay
plus all customers can get in on the
Super Bowl 57 excitement with DraftKings
happy hour super boost
DraftKings it's just freaking awesome I
have fun I did a corporate gig for
DraftKings last year uh last week and
they're just the best people too like
genuinely got to meet some of the people
who created it and just awesome awesome
people I really do love DraftKings right
now download the DraftKings Sportsbook
app and use code hey babe new customers
bet five dollars on Super Bowl 57 and
get 200 and free bets instantly only at
DraftKings Sportsbook with code hey babe
so you got to put in that code hey babe
to get that offer it's awesome minimum
age and eligibility restrictions apply
void in Ohio see show notes for details
door Dash I love it Sal loves it pat
salaha loves it homeless pimp loves it
everybody loves doordash everybody uses
doordash if you don't use doordash I
genuinely don't talk to you you're not
welcome in my house door Dash is awesome
okay first of all you know they work
with all the top food chains every
Popeyes Cheesecake Factory whatever you
want doordash has it and what they're
doing now is you can you can literally
with doordash you can get groceries I
mean you can it's more than just food
whatever you want doordash has and uh
and you can get an annual membership now
I like this annual membership less than
50 a year for unlimited zero delivery
fees okay it is so worth it zero
delivery fees exclusive items more than
twenty five thousand member uh members
only offers Nationwide dash pass for the
students because listen it's all about
the students all about the kids and this
doordash delivery with dash pass with
dash pass is just 4.99 a month for
students it's literally so worth it a
lot of students listen to the show get
that dash pass 4.99 a month for a
limited time our listeners are going to
get 50 off up to a 20 value and zero
dollar delivery fees when you download
the doordash app and enter code hey
babe23 that's 50 off up to a 20 value
and zero dollar delivery fees when you
download the doordash app in the app
store and enter code hey babe23 do not
forget that's code hey babe23 fifty
percent off up to a twenty dollar value
and zero dollar delivery fees with
doordash subject to change terms apply
here's another rule that I've been
trying to live by if I don't know you
personally or if you're not a family
member or a friend I can see an opinion
you may have on TV or Tick Tock or
whatever but I'm not gonna let it ruin
my day at all because I don't know you I
only know the edited version what you've
put out to represent yourself because
people make it their whole identity to
hate a politician an actor a president
right it's ridiculous to me yeah you're
you're you're you're the algorithm is
getting to stop the hate the math
equation is getting to you only if I if
I know you personally then I can give
you some time in my day what's your
response my response is if it may have
the floor uh is it do you do you tell
yourself
to not let it bother you or have you
achieved a status where it rolls off and
you need no extra effort to convince
yourself to not let it bother you that
depends please that
I appreciate your question that depends
there aren't I will tell you what
happens what sometimes instantly I'm
like no sometimes if I'm in a different
place I'll start to get upset about
something I heard from someone I don't
know and I didn't like what that person
said and I'm letting it affect me but
quickly a lot quicker than ever I have
before I check myself before I wreck
myself because yeah because big dicks in
the ass is bad for your health and so a
shotgun they say it's bad for your
health but the evidence is always
changing whatever Dr Oz says I listen to
and a Dr Oz hasn't commented on that yet
yeah honestly I used to be I used to
like Dr Oz but didn't he go loopy yeah
the people he fell off yeah yeah yeah
he was like people loved him oh he was
not I mean he was the guy and then did
he get political or something like that
is that what happened uh yeah well he
became uh he ran he became Republican
and that's so funny because didn't Oprah
launch him
and then Oprah backed his uh
political rival yes who won that the
Pennsylvania the one that opened back to
one and right Oprah's not on anymore is
she is Oprah's still on didn't he wasn't
he always on the Oprah Winfrey show did
Oprah put out new episodes where's Oprah
where
has Oprah been up to does she put out
new apps no right
oh no because it was a big deal the last
Oprah she's got a podcast
oh wow she has a podcast now that's it
well she sponsors my athletic greens I
don't think so well I don't know if we
are this episode she's like
Oprah's like can I talk to you for a
minute about magic spoon yeah
um she's she's now we're on the same
level as Oprah now
we have a podcast in a sense you and I
are the new oprahs I feel like right
yeah don't you feel like we're the new
Oprah yeah I feel me plus you equals
Oprah let me ask you a question okay and
I want you to answer me serious I want
you to take him back I'm the only I only
want to be serious on this podcast from
now on okay so for the next for the next
five minutes let's try it okay let's be
dead serious dead serious for the next
five minutes got it okay
if it didn't take your family out of it
but everything about you is your the
same your identity your experiences who
you are how you feel about yourself your
body everything right now take the
family out of it
if you
were presented the opportunity to swap
with Oprah
you become Oprah like that body swap
kind of thing you you could click your
fingers and now you have your mind but
your Oprah's life Oprah's body Oprah's
experiences and Oprah becomes in your
body don't worry about that part would
you obey I'm being serious sorry
would you abandon your body and live as
Oprah
now take into consideration
the things that Oprah has namely a
couple billion dollars but it's not all
for the money you're also gonna in in in
inhabit the brain and and body of a
middle-aged to older black woman which I
believe I relate to more than anyone
older Jewish men and older black women
Yeah but I
I'll tell you this Sal if I get more
than Tyler Perry money like if if you
gave me that opportunity yeah I think I
would how long would it be four did you
say
I just said like you switch with her so
I that's a good that's a good caveat
because I don't think it would be maybe
for life but if you could go if you
could be open for one year and then you
come back to yourself but let me ask you
a question am I Oprah I'm I'm fully
Oprah yes but do I still have like am I
still the kid's dad
yeah but I'm taking the kids to school
I'm it's Dad it's daddy daughter dance
but I'm Oprah no what I would think is
like don't take the kids out of the
equation fully right like don't worry
about like maybe you don't have like
when you swe when I switch to Oprah just
how Oprah doesn't know about my life
Oprah I'm in Oprah's world yeah correct
I don't even know my children exist
correct
got it so I'm fully living as Oprah yeah
I would say I would you can remove
yourself from the kids that's the thing
you gotta do just think about right
would you be interested to live Oprah's
daily life and have Oprah's mind and and
and be This Woman This famous woman
right who has pioneered magazines
television networks and things of that
nature I would imagine that there's a
lot of pressure to be Oprah but anymore
we didn't even know what she was up to
she's doing a podcast now she's just
she's actually to be honest with you
Oprah's competition now is what she is
yes so what I what I'll say to that then
is I absolutely would become her I would
be her and become her because the grand
plan would say what I would do as my
Oprah is I would I would drive that
podcast to the ground I would watch hey
babe go up okay and Oprah go down you
think she's a direct competitor then I
would think that the only people we
compete with for podcasting on this
planet is Joe Rogan and Oprah yeah yeah
I would agree and especially now that
we're being serious with being dead
serious yeah and by the way let me tell
you that I believe Joe Rogan is the
Oprah of the straight white male
community uh
uh it's bold that's bold but I agree and
they both like archery
let me ask you a question if you were
like a restaurant right and Oprah was
there and you were like coming in she
was leaving whatever it was and she
passed you and gave you a stern word for
she doesn't know you but maybe she was
having a bad movie you bumped into her
she bumped into you anyway she just said
something and she spoke up a little bit
right
don't be bumping into me unvaccinated
something like that right yeah you're
you though for real and she's really hot
okay yeah she's you you're her she's
yeah she's you're you're you she's her
yeah would you would you have a uh equip
or stern word for her back would you
have a backbone with Oprah if she if she
said something in passing that was a
little bit uh aggressive or a little bit
like uh like you know she gave you a
quip would you have a quick back or
would you be fujifier Oprah and would
you bow would you just be like let me
back that's a good question that's Oprah
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna sass oh
Oprah if Oprah sassed you would you sass
her back or would you be like
I'm gonna take a to clap back at Oprah
yeah would you clap back I'm gonna say
she clapped at you she clapped at me I'm
gonna say
right now that probably I'm going to
tell you that the answer is yes I'll
clap back right wow but that's because
we're not really in the situation right
if I'm going to be truly honest with you
is what you said we need to do for the
next five minutes this is serious and be
honest yes because the rest of the time
I'm usually lying and and being silly
but to be truly honest with you I think
that at that time with Oprah I would
probably say nothing what I would do in
the moment is I'd say nothing but then
I'd immediately call you and tell you I
just cursed Oprah out okay you told her
what a piece of garbage she was Color
Purple sucks right Steadman's gay right
I would say all that stuff you know yeah
well I'm not laughing because that is
serious yes that is serious but I think
what I would do is in the I would I
would hope and pray that there's no
video evidence because I I spewed a lie
to you okay you were lying to me but in
the minute you would cave okay because I
have this thing like okay I will not let
anyone disrespect me I don't care who
you are right so I think I might I might
it's tough because it's Oprah but if
she's out of pocket yeah I like that
saying I like that if she's out of
pocket I there's no reason that I can't
stick up for myself or give her a stern
word right and I feel like give her
Howard work if she tested me yeah I feel
like I would have something to say about
I'm not saying I would be disrespectful
I wouldn't immediately like immediately
like curse her out or anything but I
might be like excuse you you know uh
you're out of line you're in a pocket
you're out of pocket yeah and I'd say I
I won't stand for that who do you think
you are just because of your
accomplishments and your money you think
you can treat another human being like
that yeah I say no that yeah do that
yeah not a red line I would say not a
Red Lobster I would say what my
grandfather's response would always be
if anybody said something like that to
him or or or or disrespected him I've
heard him say this many times he would
say hey call it we're all leaving here
in this we're all leaving here the same
way in a box oh you would always say
that it's kind of lovely doesn't say it
doesn't matter who you think we're all
leaving here the same way in a box and I
would always say what about the people
who choose to be cremated that's right
yeah and you just that's a that's a
loophole in the whole thing what about
people who died it drowned in the sea uh
they're not in a box did he feel ashamed
after you called him out he would he
would then make believe that he was hard
of hearing okay he just kept and then
he'd buy me a toy if if I tied your arm
behind what's your dominant arm oh uh
right on if I tied your right arm behind
your back and tied your legs together
okay and I I'm hogtied at the feet on my
arms behind my back okay one arm your
Dom on okay and hog tied at the feet and
I lay you on your back could you beat
Oprah in a fight
she's she's fully up and she has all her
limbs
I would say no only because if I'm Oprah
you're on your back
yeah because if I'm Oprah first of all
if I'm Oprah then I've been I've been uh
at least Shadow Boxing daily
because that that's what I do if I was
if I was Oprah I'd at least be Shadow
Boxing and at least be uh attempting to
do Jiu Jitsu classes once or twice a
week on Staten Island
so I would say no I would say I couldn't
beat her up she's five seven
she's five seven so if she knew how to
give you like Maya Angelou is six feet
no she wasn't it just said go back Pat
it just said Maya Angelou is six feet
tall she's dunking on hoes Steadman is
six seven Stedman is six six seven he's
an entire foot taller than Oprah that's
that's crazy six seven what do you think
life's like for a person who's six seven
I think it's not good you really I think
that it's probably
better except for scenarios when you're
at a movie theater or concert and you're
the [__] that's blocking everyone
behind you but other than that like it
must be nice to hover above everybody
yeah like if you're walking in the
airport like no one's as tall as you
yeah but then there's other there's
problems like I always think about like
every time I'm on a roller coaster and
you go on a roller coaster you know like
they're trying to make like you know the
drop and like you're going through
things fast there's a lot of times where
like there'll be some obstacle on a
roller coaster track like a cover or
like whatever and I'm like if you're you
you could get beheaded on one of these
things if you're decapitated if you're
you're like a truck on the expressway or
yeah exactly exactly or like you know uh
uh you know if you're at a water park or
something like that you'll get your head
you can't you could be too tall for
certain things on an airplane you're too
tall yeah you could be too tall so you
you would opt out of being six seven
just based on water parks yes six four
six four and a half is what I'd say I
still ball will you bowl right now and
watches but I'm balling at six feet I'm
balling like I'm I'm Maya Angelou's
height you and Maya Angelou are the same
exact height Maya Angelou and I are
literally where I you if you put Maya
Angelou and I in a room it's tough to
tell who's who if I tied your hands
behind your back and sat you in a chair
and Maya Angelou was allowed to slap you
across the face one at a time but
repeatedly how many slaps before you
fall down three okay three I'm on the
floor because she's six feet tall okay
three slaps three have you seen the new
slap that new slap competition no is it
a tick tock the slap League oh what's
this Pat pull up the slap dude the MMA
uh the the UFC Pat do you know about
this they invested in a power slap
League where guys just take turns I
guess women on them too oh and this is
bad because of the Dana White slap
yeah well I guess but no I I'm saying I
think that's why I heard about it where
it's like he can't be a part of this
league or something but oh is that right
something yeah he was because he stopped
his wife yeah well no this is oh my god
dude they just take turns and dude this
they can cut I mean it's like instant
CTE just dead [__] just add chalk
what it's dude
it's crazy dude
oh dude it's it's insane like why okay
ready I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you
something right
the powder oh but uh
okay and then just
can I explain wow can I explain that
this person's head is his brain I mean
it's so wait so we watched the other day
I watched a clip of the whole like the
last thing of the tournament the guy who
won the gold the belt the champion who
won the belt his head half his head he
wasn't getting because you guys stopped
on the same side it was a normal head a
normal head and a head this big show
that show that the slap Champion you're
not gonna believe what his head looks
like it's permanent it's permanent
damage to his skull after after the
competition he won he won the belt
because the other guy gave up wait you
gotta show this guy's head it's in the
news okay it was like it was all over
his face
that guy right there show him after he
got empty yes yeah oh my God okay it
that it was even worse than that he but
my question to you is this because it's
swelling look at him oh my God okay he
looks like bismarcki
you have to keep getting slapped on the
same side until someone gives up I think
yeah so check this oh you get knocked
out okay he he won he's the champion oh
my God he won right that's what his face
so he got the belt do you know what his
you know the cash price was what five
thousand dollars a professional sports
League bought by the UFC sanctioned in
as as a sport it's a professional sport
now and he got that that's his face and
the prize was five thousand dollars it's
it it feels like like what are people
thinking why do you want to do that he
could literally have taken a just a just
a few extra shifts at like Target yeah
and made that money and now and now he
and he has six foot Maya Angelou again
yeah and now dunking on hoes look at
that
God bless her I'll tell you what I don't
want to go in a slap League against Maya
Angelou he's got some pause uh To Kill a
Mockingbird what is my Angelo Harper Lee
is the uh kill a monkey but to kill him
what is Maya Angelou she's a she's a
poet no but what's the famous One what's
my Angelo's most famous poet I've got a
lot are you sure you're not thinking of
uh
I mean she's prolific I think no but
there's one
uh oh I Know Why the Caged Bird Sings
okay that's you see where I got to Kill
a Mockingbird Cage Bird Sings I like the
connection okay no no no no where's
there
um okay so let me get to this yeah I was
saying I know we had ADHD a few times in
this one because there was other things
I wanted to get back to but we're
forgetting but we'll do it next week
okay now that's the beauty about having
a pot with this there's no off season
okay okay so so I watched
now I'm 38 years old okay I'm
respectfully 38. prove it
allegedly allegedly um I'm 38 years old
and I watched on uh um
and I'm and by the way I don't think I'm
a goody two shoes I think I'm 38 years
old but I think you know we have the
podcast where Comics pretty you know I'm
not conservative I'm like anything goes
I don't know I'm not being horrified and
offended by unlike whatever dude live
life sure I watched a movie that we've
seen many many times you know I'm sure
you've seen it we've all seen it you
know people our age Pat probably has
even seen it how old are you Pat
26. God bless you God bless
and I this movie came out in the mid 90s
it was controversial back then it's
still controversial but when I watched
this police in my airport in my hotel
room okay uh in Phoenix this past
weekend
I truly felt horrified I felt like I
don't want my kids to see this this is
not good have you ever guessed yes have
you recently rewatched this have you
watched this movie recently okay any any
clues that like won't give it away
mid 90s okay give me the genre of film
it is a kind of um it's not a DOT it's
it's a slice of life
uh yeah drama movie okay couple of uh
one huge star was their first role in
this movie child
um okay that's a sense so the the the
the star well no it's not the star
a teenager
you know it
What's the guess oh What's Eating
Gilbert great no it's not What's Eating
Gilbert Grape but that's a good Johnny
Depp I mean not Johnny uh that's a good
guess this it it it it was a movie that
when you watch it today you're like man
this is tough to watch uh because of
what because of what is you're just it's
tough to watch and when I was watching
it back then as a kid and even a guy in
my 20s I didn't even understand
watching this movie like what really is
happening here oh yeah okay and it came
out in the name and it's by the way a
great movie a cult movie a classic movie
a cool movie but but the main character
what he's doing is like when you watch
it today or as watching it as a a guy
who's a little bit older I was like man
this is making me feel like I'm not
enjoying this I'm like I want to kill
this kid oh whoa yeah and it's mid 90s
mid 90s 1995. okay Operation Dumbo Drop
it's not Rookie of the Year either okay
um not little giants oh yeah
um oh wow because now it's like you've
given me a lot of information I'll say
the title of the movie is one word okay
oh powder close Okay uh the setting is
New York City it's downtown Bohemia
Bohemian New York City downtown Bohemia
like like Lower Manhattan Vibes like
cool kids
I just said the word oh kids kids yes
the movie kids oh that was crazy
controversial when it came out right but
now people thought it was real the way
he shot it was it was that Harmony
Korean who was the harmony Korean and uh
um what's the other what's it Larry
Charles is it no I don't think so is it
Larry Charles is the producer writer and
director for Seinfeld
[Laughter]
no Rosario Dawson oh yes for sperms yeah
that was her yeah I forgot about that
she's not even on the top building no
that's how she got discovered she was
sitting on a stoop and uh you know Larry
Clark discovered her now you're singing
I completely picture her face to watch
it man because you can only watch it on
Supreme's website you can't watch it
it's not on YouTube it's not even
Supreme's website so I think that the
movie kids is banned in the United
States you can't even buy it I couldn't
on my phone you could only watch it on
Supreme's website why Supreme because I
don't know they were playing it I think
Leo Fitzpatrick at one time was a
skateboard this skateboarder is in the
movie
um but but but I remember seeing it
people were like is this real I swear to
God the way he shot it was almost like
but Telly that the main actor Telly Leo
Fitzpatrick does a great job late
uh lead actor Oh I thought he said
Casper died the kid who played Casper
died he did because wasn't he in Friday
yeah and he hung himself yeah 25 years
old and then the one of the other kids
the skateboarders died of a cocaine
overdose oh um at 31 yeah some sadness
attached to the movie but
um you know the movie is just telly
raping 13 year old girls giving them
AIDS yeah that's the movie that is what
the that is what the your a character is
doing throughout the movie that is his
main motivation and every scene is too
isn't the girl passed out or something
girls yeah he's raping girls yeah and
then unknowingly giving them AIDS that's
and it just made me feel like
uncomfortable and I'm again I'm not a
[__] prude I I'm but I was like oh
man like I would never like this is bad
but that was the sentiment when it came
out oh okay so there's nothing new I'm
not giving anybody new wait I have a
controversial opinion
so when you originally when you
originally watch it it was just a it
just was a you know just a fun little
movie yeah it was a it was a
lighthearted laugh yeah Friday night
laughs yeah you did you didn't register
that he was yeah raping unconscious
girls yeah okay it was just like the
skateboarding was cool right right yeah
no I remember that thing was like that
rocked the world when that thing came
you see it in theaters I didn't but I
got news for you I got that [__] on VHS
oh you have it on it's a bootleg VHS I
probably don't have anything so I don't
have to go through Supreme's website
anymore I doubt I haven't anymore
is it pinned
I could but it wasn't banned so how
could it be banned because here's what
happens to me here's what happens to me
is I go on the road and watch me see my
family I watch kids you go on the road
and meet your family and watch kids and
watch kids yeah in an effort to to feel
reunited with my family
I watch kids and um no but but what
happens is I I miss New York so much and
I've been lately craving craving
nostalgic New York because I think the
new New York is open now you know post
pandemic all great but it still doesn't
feel like it fell to me like it did
pre-pandemic it doesn't feel like 2019
New York still correct it's not the
concrete jungle where dreams are made of
it's not yes so I find myself
when I'm away from New York watching
movies like kids I watch that show how
to Make It in America on HBO Max
fantastic show about again Bohemian
downtown New York City like that New
York City that I love I'll go to YouTube
and just put in walking through the
streets 1995 New York walking through
the streets 2015 New York I love it and
just random and I feel I almost like
want to cry yeah because I feel like I
don't know what it is I don't know what
has to come back to make New York feel
like it was again but like my father
says he's like you know Chris New York
he said what might have to happen is
this and I think he's right he's like
for the 70s and 80s man New York was a
war zone it was terrible but then it
came back with the Vengeance in the 90s
and to and you grew up in the New York
that my my dad said the New York City
that you grew up in New York I couldn't
even have imagined you couldn't go
anywhere near 40 seconds yeah he said so
you don't understand most of New York
feels like it does today you just lived
in its Glory years for those 20 years he
said and I probably think it would come
back but you were lit you were just you
got I was young I was born in the 70s
but I was I didn't really I guess I I
was in the city with I remember being in
the city with my dad because he was a
sanitation man yeah in the Lower East
Side yeah and I used to go with him
sometimes to work and I you know I used
to go so I was in the city a lot in the
80s used to take me to the oh even as a
kid you know we used to go to like
Madison Square Garden for the circus
yeah and we still remember like you know
like at that time and it was bad dude
but I I so funny I just watched it
I uh I got master class do you ever see
that oh yeah like like Judd Apatow does
it and like yeah it's like all different
people all professionals from all
different walks of life anywhere from
like chefs to filmmakers to writers to
musicians to
cops and they tell those stories and I
just watched a special document about
this guy uh who was a hostage negotiator
and he does this whole series about how
to read people's body language how to
know the line and then he did he they
did a doc on wait what was his name this
guy it was Rick Rich Rick Rick Rick Voss
because I think I went to school Chris
Voss they went to college with his
daughter really yeah I went to college
with a girl whose dad was like a master
hostage no that's not him
he had a hostage situation in a bank in
Brooklyn in like 1992 or something like
that where he was negotiating he was The
Negotiator there was three gunmen and
three hostages okay in Carroll Gardens
in Brooklyn Street in like a Chase right
and they did the whole Doc and it was it
was it was Shadow Chase Bank you know
really Sapphire rewards but it's good I
mean you're online graphic user
interfaces number one I think yeah yeah
so they what they did was it was all
over the news though they were reporting
like there was a hundred cop cars SWAT
everything so it was they had all the
news reports so they showed all the
clips from it and I saw like New York
Brooklyn like 92 whatever it was and it
was so nostalgic to watch it right
because I was like oh my God I missed
that yeah even just back then this is
the cop car or the cars themselves and
like not everything was as we're just
getting more and more sanitized and more
and more homogenized now right where
everything's a [__] Santander Bank
but like right when I say grit from the
70s and 80s you think
crime because that came along with that
time period but I'm not talking about
crime so much as I'm talking about
much more mom-and-pop businesses yes
much more uh culture yeah you know and
much more like you know like even like
the things like the Lower East Side like
that was as whatever it is now is a
remnant of what that you know that
neighborhood used to be yeah it was like
movements you know there was hip-hop and
it was uh everything punk rock and it
was like all this [__] like this pop art
like all this like uh street art and
stuff and I I think that we seriously
forget sometimes because again being
desanitized or just life goes on and our
brains have to kind of change things to
make it palatable for us it's just like
what humans do but I think like we
really forget like how truly different
our world has been since 9 11. like yeah
it radical the United States at least
yeah well at least the Northeast New
York City radically changed like change
like you can't imagine yeah since 9 11.
and it was like like little by little
that day it changed everything and then
of course the pandemic even more but I
agree like the mom and pops like like
Jerry you know came over before TT Jerry
and you know I'll go get uh you know oh
you got to go have this egg sandwich in
Manhattan some twelve dollar 13 sandwich
or this place or that place he went to
like the deli on 4th Avenue and 59th
Street in Bay Ridge the best bacon egg
and cheese sandwich I've ever had in my
life there was a bacon egg and cheese on
hot bread like uh I guess it was like a
Puerto Rican Bakery that he goes to like
five dollars you just gotta know where
to go bro just gotta know where to go
that and that's what New York City is we
just got to know yeah and I feel like
when I was watching you know these movie
kids and how to Make It in America or
this old school Nostalgia stuff I was
like I was like that's the New York I
remember this is the New York you miss
that's the New York I missed but I was
thinking you and I we gotta make a show
or a movie we got because you and I know
nostalgic New York yeah that would kill
today like bring that back with the
dramedy stories that we all have from
scripted scripted scripted let's do
scripted old New York let's do it that I
think that that's period piece though
period piece baby they been doing period
pieces yeah I've Chippendales as a
period piece was it what was that movie
that Santino with Kamal and Johnny yeah
yeah and
um um um um wasn't uh I love Camille
yeah he's great was it was it act jacked
yeah even not Jack though I've liked him
since he was right I liked it I liked
him since he was soft-bodied yes uh
First Open Mic I ever did was this place
called Larry and evil Mike's Open Mic at
Parkside Lounge on uh East Houston
Street I was doing open mics and I
remember my uh I went into that open mic
and uh I got a pitcher of beer I was
very nervous I got a pitcher of beer and
I just sat in the back and I was going
up like 50th or whatever yeah and the
comic right before me was Kumail
what year
2009 okay I'll tell you right right now
and he was fantastic yeah my bar that I
used to work at over here cargo Cafe
yeah I used to do uh produce a grab ass
comedy on Tuesday nights for like three
four years over the years you produced
it uh it was from 2000 I want to call it
2008 to 12 maybe okay and um
we had everybody come over there I don't
know if did you ever did I did it I did
you did you weren't there though okay I
did I did that I mean we had everybody
we had everybody produced a show there
once oh that wasn't my show that's what
I'm saying I did your Venue I got your
show okay yeah that makes sense yeah he
did it but we had I mean we had Jay we
had soda we had Colin Joe we had
everybody came up everyone right and uh
Kumail used to come do the show and and
I remember like it was he was good
already but I like that's when I met him
I remember one guy that made him two
Pineapple pineapple Martini I got him
wasted yeah yeah Betty what now now he
wouldn't do that now now put a little
creatine who the hell were we saying I
was about to say back up Kumail oh I was
saying that Santino was in that uh
period piece movie with comedians oh um
um dying up here yeah I'm dying up here
by the way Andrew Santino's new Netflix
special cheeseburger great check it out
yes Burger yeah oh and then and then I I
want to talk about
um the a movie I saw on Netflix
um called uh you people did you see you
people oh
Schultz is in it Sam J is excellent in
it Jonah Hill Julia Louis Dreyfus David
Duchovny
how did you remember all these people
it's how I roll I'm on Prednisone it's
scripted yeah it's a scripted show about
um Jonah Hill and his well I'm not sure
yes yes she's great that Eddie Murphy
Jonah Hill starts dating Eddie Murphy's
daughter or something like that yes
she's great actress I've just all those
people are in it everybody yeah every uh
Jonah wrote did Jonah wrote it right
Lauren London Jonah wrote it I think I
think he wrote Nia Long
um Sam J is truly tacos in it Young
Rhea Perlman Mike Epps is funny bro and
Brian Greenberg from How to Make It in
America isn't it okay Dion call at one
point how are all these people in it
Matt Walsh no it's it's a great movie uh
uh Mike Epps calls Jonah Hill a credit
card he goes his credit card
[__] I'm gonna give you a swipe
I don't know what it meant but I laughed
out loud
I gotta watch that yeah uh I you know we
should have someone here Perlman I know
I haven't seen her in a minute guess who
Rhea perlman's married to Danny DeVito
this has been hey babe thank you so much
thank you
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe hey babe